vous vous êtes favorable bien sûr c'est
déjà à rennes c'est déjà dans certains
pays ça va arriver à grenoble enfin tout
le monde pourra aller à la piscine enfin
il n'y aura plus de discrimination c'est
comme le fait de jouer au foot pour des
femmes voilées je suis totalement pour
il ya des jeunes femmes qui ne peuvent
pas aller à la piscine banal pourront
donc c'est une initiative que je trouve
formidable et qui va contre toutes les
discriminations et pour la
réconciliation en france je voudrais un
nom daniel moreau en fait au départ
c'est pour des raisons d'hygiène on
embête les garçons par exemple mais qui
ne doivent pas avoir sans les shorts
flottant ou des choses comme ça donc des
oliviers mais moi je la défense du
maillot away boulot oui c'est ça c'est
pas nul hein y'a quand même très fort et
puis moi ça m'énerve à monsieur regardez
c'est évidemment je ne vais pas mettre
ça sur le même plan pour pas me faire
mais l'autre jour dans une piscine
allemande on pouvait se mettre seins nus
parce que pour l'égalité des sexes moi
j'aimerais que dans ces lieux là on en
est on en enlève la politique et la
religion et qu'on soit dans des toiles
et ses dires et que voit la fatigue ou
bah oui oui et non mais ça m'est
déjà pour les jeunes ça me gêne voilà
les ou alors on fait vraiment libéral
baïocco
maillot lé bal est assez à l'évasion
sienne on va aller on va aller nager
ensemble la sirène
sais rien moi c'est daniel arrête avec
l'argument de l'hygiène c'est bidon les
gens ça les dérange c'est de voir des
femmes qui cachent leur corps à la
piscine moi je suis pas du tout d'accord
avec ça je suis évidemment pour le
burqini il y a qu'en france que ça
dérange les gens en grande bretagne a
aucun problème et puis il faut répondre
aux gens qui ont des arguments contre le
burkina qui disent que ça oblige les
femmes à cacher leurs corps qui a aussi
des arguments contre le maillot de bain
le maillot demain s'est aussi imposé une
certaine forme de nudité à certaines
femmes qui n'ont pas forcément envie de
se montrer nue partiellement qu'elles
soient musulmanes ou non d'ailleurs donc
je pense que chaque femme doit être
libre de s'habiller comme elle le veut
pour aller à la piscine ou à la plage
donc voilà without et hypocrite dans ton
argument guillaume c'est que ce vêtement
la 1re v1
un caractère religieuse qu'il n'y a pas
dans le maillot de bain tutubes il
compare à un maillot de bain
traditionnel à normale entre guillemets
puisque ce même
mois moi ce qui m'interroge tout
simplement c il ya des femmes
effectivement qui porte le burqini de
façon volontaire il ya d'autres femmes
qui le portent à ce qu'elles n'ont pas
le chois pression sociale pression
familiale pression la religieuse etc etc
donc quid de ces femmes là en fait et
qu'est ce qu'on va faire à l'entrée on
va te dire tu le portes pourquoi toi à
toi tu le fais parce que c'est ton plein
gré toi tu fais pas ce que ton mari veut
te dit que tu le fasses comment on va
faire et donc moi parce qu' il peut y en
avoir juste une qu'il qu'il ne fait pas
ce qu'elle n'a pas le choix juste pour
celles là moi je dis que il faut qu'on
soit de notre à la piscine c'est juste
pour ça kelly qui tombant non moi ça me
plaît je veux bien voir des femmes à
poil je veux bien avoir des femmes avec
le burqini je veux bien tout voir en
fait certainement la piscine ensemble
c'est vital pour elle et que je me
saisir visuellement moi ça me dérangera
pas donc non répond pas on parle de une
ou deux femmes qui vont qu'on va voir la
piscine de notre vie enfin combien de
femmes vont se retrouver en burqini à la
piscine moi le problème dans tout ça
c'est la stigmatisation de toute une
partie de la population d'une religion
et ça me dérange parce que quand on a ce
genre de débat est bon on imagine que
toutes les femmes musulmanes de france
vont aller à la piscine en burqini alors
que c'est faux c'est une toute petite
minorité donc ça ça me pose un problème
oui moi ça me gêne vraiment ce que dit
valérie c'est que vous présupposés parce
que c'est la religion musulmane que
certaines femmes vont être obligés de
mettre un burqini mais vous rendez
compte on dit pas ça
désormais vous présupposés mais savez
pas vous présupposés et laisser la
liberté aux gens d'aller à la piscine en
burqini c'est le vol des ac est érigé le
droit d'y voir aussi à la fois un
maillot un entre guillemets un maillot
de bain mais je peux aussi y voir un
outil de propagande islam politique
qu'elle doit me voir et pourquoi le mur
comme il sera un outil de propagande
bien cela me fait même temps dans tous
les rangs du tap ce que vous dites c'est
redoutable je ne dis pas que c'est le
cas dans 100% des cas mais il se peut
qu'il y ait aussi parmi ces femmes des
femmes qui subissent le burqini et au
nom de ces femmes là moi je me sens une
femme qui a envie de les défendre et qui
dit ben écoute tu sais quoi moi je vais
protéger j'ai entre guillemets parce que
je vais faire que celui à est un lieu où
toutes les femmes sont égales c'est à
dire toutes les femmes elles sont avec
pas de représentation pasanen je ne
parle pas mais au même titre que par
exemple les religieuses orthodoxes
juives ben pareil à billets non plus je
refuse ce qu'elle dise oui mais le truc
je veux qu'ils me joindre à sa vie parce
qu'elle ira pas la piscine là il ira à
la plage mais à la plage ce sera
interdit aussi non non
alors a pas le droit parce que vous ne
voulez pas parce que vous voulez pas du
burkini d'aller à la piscine c'est ça la
conclusion vous empêcher des familles
s'y perd et c'est pour ça que j'aime
lorsque vous dites et vous fait peur je
ne sais pas où le burkina élections
c'est quand même c'est vrai ça lire ici
non non je je ne te dis pas que j'ai
interdit à ces jeux par mois il me
semble qu'il ya des espaces par exemple
l'espace public dans la rue je suis par
exemple pour le voile je pense que les
femmes ont droit d'être dans la rue avec
leur voile ça ne me pose aucun problème
en revanche il y à des endroits où il me
semble que parce que dans la rue elles
vont faire leurs courses elles vont
travailler et c'est là on est dans un
cadre de loisirs dans ce cadre là moi ça
me pose un souci parce que ce vêtement
là en l'occurrence ce ce burqini mon
pour moi m'interroge le voile ne
m'interroge pas dans l'espace public ils
m'interrogent l'a donc dans ce cadre là
de la piscine dans ce burkina
m'interroge voilà les breuvachons à la
place des gens comme ça parce que c'est
une burqini on se dit c'est forcément
une pression sociale qui est subi en
revanche on parle pas de la pression
sociale peut être que ressentent des
femmes qui sont vite se mettre en
maillot de bain de se mettre à motiver
ses
amis et quand c'est des femmes
musulmanes de pression sociale on parle
à la place des gens quand c'est le
maillot de bain et qui a pas de religion
on parle pas donc pour moi c'est vrai
poids deux mesures alors déjà je pense
que piol il en a rien à [ __ ] de l'été
il est juste dans une démarche
législative alors qu'il arrivait avec là
elle fait enfin à la france insoumise et
donc la lui il est juste de ce côté là
donc il a marre elle a faussé de du
clientélisme essais de losail a
longtemps il y en avait déjà parlé mais
ce qu'il a gagné grenoble grâce à une
alliance avec la france insoumise donc
effectivement depuis le début c'est son
cheval de bataille ça c'est le premier
truc deuxièmement je sais pas si on peut
avoir une discussion sereine aujourd'hui
si on se prononce contre le port du
burkini moi je suis d'accord avec tout
ce qu'a dit valérie est ce qu on est
raciste est-ce qu'on islamophobe voilà
tout d'un coup on est tout de suite
montré du doigt on n'a pas le droit moi
je trouve que l on droit oui du point de
vue de la loi ensuite est ce qu'on peut
dire que le burqini est un vêtement
comme les autres et bien non je pense
que le bir qui n'est pas un vêtement
comme les autres c'est pas un maillot
comme les autres ça instaure malgré tout
une différence entre le corps de la
femme et le corps de l'homme et moi à
titre personnel en tant que citoyenne
française ça me dérange je pense à
toutes ces femmes dans les pays comme
l'iran par exemple qui veulent justement
enlever leurs bikinis et qui se font
menacer de mort qui se font lapider qui
sont emprisonnés alors à ce moment là si
c'est pas le patriarcat si c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on t'impose bas ce
moment là tu mets un burqini hockey et
puis tu es en iran est battu mais plutôt
dire qu'ils nient ok mais là bas c'est
pas possible donc ça veut dire que
malgré tout et valérie a raison le
burqini n'est pas si anodin que ce que
vous voulez bien vous dire voilà c'est
tout ouais bah tu risques de te dis que
tu t'en foutais ouais non pas contre le
mec est musulman il va tour se noue
ouais bah oui il ya une différence entre
le corps de la femme et le corps de la
communauté demandent à rachida dati
qu'elle peut on demander à sonia mabrouk
cela peut demander aux femmes musulmanes
qui sont pour une laïcité aujourd'hui en
france du corps des femmes de mon art si
ce qu'elle pense il y en a qui sont très
heureuses au site pour plein mais moi je
pense que c'est le choix de chaque
université cadi leur ai dit le voile le
voilà
les rangs incroyable les rayons halal
tout ça mais rien ne me dérange moins
que les gens fassent leur religion rien
ne me dérange là tu parles du voile le
voyant que fait le choix de gilles
circuit le football le football rien ne
me dérange que quelqu'un elle joue avec
un enviable bien ça ne me dérange pas
sauf que là moi j'aime bien ma ma france
d'avant quand j'étais petit mois il y
avait des enfants musulmans il y avait
des filles musulmanes elles mangeaient
pas port al zaala la piscine en maillot
de bain ça se passait très bien pourquoi
on cherche à changer les noms mais comme
ça non mais pourquoi on veut tout le
temps changent et les trucs à
l'exclusion est différent dès lundi j'ai
déjà même le mec qui ont short de bain
je ne supporte pas déjà moi je m'étais
s'asseoir sur tous les bancs de la
france et il vient se baigner à côté de
moi déjà lui je ne supporte pas à manger
là il est là ce sont non mais ça en
avant avec le voile on peut être
tolérant mais on peut être ne pas dire
string ne manie pas mais on peut se dire
que le burkina dans les piscines non
mais alors ce qu'on pensait
téléspectateurs tiens oui à 18% nous à
81% alors voilà bravo mr d'avoir fait ça
ce soir avec la fête de la fin du
ramadan il a sorti ça aujourd'hui les
broadway tu crois pas j'ai fait une
lettre au président républicain
allez parler d'écologie dans autre chose
ça qui fait 2 % des mecs ils font les
mêmes mauvais comptes ça n'a rien à voir
avec la fin du ramadan c'est un jour
d'hui
d'intégration chaînon penser ce qu'on
veut c'est qu'ils ont des années
ne
sont pas aperçu le combat écologique
c'est un combat formidable ça laisse à
peine voilés
les 4% ou les 5% des élections
présidentielles ça vient un peu c est
juste je suis retrouvé devant un vrai
musulman pratiquant très très bas qui
comptent se met pas torse nu non plus à
la piscine un y exhalent a donc au fond
du trou sinon parce qu'il sait que les
extrêmes après son content avec ça
serait grave si vous rêvez vous rêvez ne
rêvez pas